usually when I hear I'm going to talk to
somebody and they've written a book
I get this feeling of apprehension which
is I gotta read the book and they booked
you
and I'm very excited and then I hear
um Stephen wrote a novel
and
I'm immediately very intrigued
so I get sent this copy of Harold which
is this novel you wrote and it's
beautiful it's really funny and touching
it's beautifully written
I think only you could write this
and I I love it I just I really do and
it was such a nice thing for me to read
the book and then know I get to go and
drive in and talk to tell Steven you got
here a little early and I heard you were
hanging out outside like a creep but I
was so excited I won I had the book and
I wanted to go down and tell you I need
to tell you how much I like your book I
really appreciate it and it's funny
because you mentioned Vonnegut and I'm
like I can feel like there's a there's
different strains like you say there's a
soup but there's I can see like Joseph
Heller and Vonnegut there's a but it's
very sweet and also at times sad and
there's such funny stuff in here
and it's all from the mind of
an eight-year-old seven or eight
seven yeah I didn't read it that
thoroughly
I just skimmed to get it I just skimmed
to get his age I'm very good at it and
I'm pretty you know that's the one thing
I will read is the age no but I was
I think eight would have been the better
choice but that's my stew brain versus
your consummate brain I don't know my
broth point but you know first of all
one of the first things that that struck
me because I'm so obsessed with myself
is I read this I read this thing at the
front
by uh by the uh the editor of the book
from Simon and Schuster who's clearly a
big deal editor and he's talking about
how
he stumbled upon you doing a set on my
show and interview on my show oh yes and
he talks about how this is why it all
comes together he talks about how he's
always been a fan of yours and then he
said uh he sits here at the top of the
book
um he's
starting to think about you know what
could I do with Steven Wright and then
he said I'd only started my job
um I guess it's Simon Schuster and I was
spending a lot of time searching the
internet trying to come up with book
ideas I can't remember what weird
YouTube algorithm led me to it but I
came across a clip of Steven Wright on
Conan O'Brien's late night show back in
2013 when he talked about writing a
novel on Twitter posting one sentence at
a time how long is the novel by now
Conan asked 1500 pages right said 1500
pages Conan said and then you say if
there's one word on each page
and then I guess he thought I gotta
check this out so he went on Twitter and
you really were doing that and then he
starts talking to you and you guys form
a friendship and you do this book so I
was just thrilled that uh that's amazing
the connection yeah yeah tremendous yeah
you would also think there might be a
financial sharing in here but we'll talk
about that later you'll hear no I love
that I love that he saw it but I love
the Serendipity of
you do this joke this guy sees that then
you start talking then uh this book
comes along and
um this book is really special because
it's a it's a boy and he's growing up in
you say the mid 60s and he's in a
classroom and he's daydreaming and
thinking
uh you know throughout the class and his
mind is taking him all around the
universe he talks about hanging out with
his grandfather and in there
great I don't want to call them jokes
but really good profound observations
and they're all very much the way a kid
would think and you have this idea about
what if people were like trees and that
they just kept getting taller as they
got older and I'd be walking down the
street as an eight-year-old
seven-year-old boy and I'd see a an 80
year old woman and she's 45 feet tall
and and you have this conversation with
her and I'm it just tickled and then
there's so many sweet things that happen
in it and it's very it's almost also has
some sort of a James Joyce quality
because it's all happening in a very
constrained period of time
but also the time is infinite because if
you're daydreaming a billion things can
happen in 45 minutes
yeah he's in the class and he's thinking
he's daydreaming he's thinking about
dreams he's had he's thinking about
experiences that he really made me think
of memories and it all is in one day and
uh
in the class I I it's great that you you
like it so much I love it how much of it
is you or do you not want to say a lot
of it a lot of a lot of it I think you
can't write anything be completely made
up you know all my see the thing is when
I I was writing it on Twitter I wrote
like on half a page on there then I
stopped and then I didn't write it for
like a year and then I thought that
thing I should keep writing it and just
keep going but I didn't put it on
Twitter so I just kept going and you
know the jokes I do are like creatively
it's like going through a narrow window
a couple sentences two three sentences
and hopefully the audience laughs you
know
okay and I'm not complaining I'm just
describing it but I had a lot of things
in my mind that wouldn't go through that
window to just be a two couple liner
joke
so I essentially used Harold's head it's
like I put a funnel on his head
and I poured into that phone everything
I think about being alive you know
religion and War and authority and the
universe and is there a god you know
that's all that's repeated all the way
through the book
is God willing if there's a God you know
I hope God if there's a God so you're
constantly questioning that throughout
yeah it was a great I didn't even know I
had all this in my head but I was a
whole other way to create it wasn't
jokes and uh
I liked writing and it wasn't a bird and
I never got like oh when is it gonna be
done oh no one was waiting for it I had
no book or deal or anything again it was
like playing like you were joking you
were joking with the thing outside and
they said oh we should use that as a bit
so I would just try to write a little
bit of it every day and then coffee I
have to thank coffee because my mind
goes insane on coffee and I would just
time would drink the coffee and had like
a two-hour window where I would just and
I it became a little world that I would
go to
and uh I tried not to think about how is
this going to be received what are they
gonna think right I was just like
playing oh oh the comedy I've always
loved the most is
when the person providing it doesn't
need to please me when I first started
writing it I realized there was no story
and I thought I can't keep this there's
no story and I thought I I don't know so
I stopped for a year
I thought I don't know how to write a
story I don't know how and I thought a
year later I thought so what just I want
to just write it anyway right so it's
not like this happened and then this
happened then he did and then because of
that so I just accepted that I didn't
know how to write a story so I just
that's just went the other thing I love
is Harold's voice very much like your
voice but imagine you as a kid but
there's a great thing where his teacher
is prominent because she's running the
class the whole time Harold is thinking
all these incredible things and having
these Journeys in his mind and every now
and at one point she uh he remembers the
time that she came up and looked at what
he was drawing and what Harold was
drawing and said that's really
beautifully done you did a really good
job here Harold and he said how dare you
judge me
it's just packed with those things so uh
I hope you write more but if all you
wrote was this that is plenty because it
is fantastic it's really good thank you
so much and I you know it's you're
such a
great uh inspirational and fascinating
person to talk to and laugh with that I
hope you come back I would love to
you're one of those people who needs to
come back I would love it and I'll have
more
we can have more competing analogies
more Super analogies bro we can maybe
change it too no our brains are like you
know crackers
a dry Dutch cracker that's got a high
seed count that's very good for your
your bowels and I'm but I'm like this
Rich Savory buttery cracker I noticed it
all yours are always oh they're good
right better than mine oh yeah I see a
pattern yeah there's a pattern here yeah
I think you are one of the fastest
incredible comedy Minds ever that's what
I would say to people what is it like
going on there I said you know what I
say something I think hope it's funny if
but if it's not it doesn't matter
because
you are like a laser it's incredible
brilliant in front of you that's huge so
I guess yes I mean that I can't believe
I feel good about myself for an hour
no coming there's no higher uh no higher
praise I could get yeah than a
compliment from you so seriously
um we all owe you I mean we all but you
changed everything for so many of us
and uh we're lucky that you came along
we really are and I was you say it's a
quirk it's an accident but you also
um and and I do think
I give it up for quirks and accidents
but there's also uh integrity and hard
work and being a good person and those
things aren't quirks so that makes it
all wonderful so thank you thank you
very much thank you let's never speak
again all right
laughs